Daniel Cormier the first time Jon Jones
probably made handles I had dinner with
Steve Bay I don't know probably three
weeks ago and he's absolutely massive is
he jack dude he's jacked like probably
255 260 like yoked yolks like in the
firehouse just lifting weights the whole
time yo so for him man he looks good
sometimes you can tell when Steve pays
mentally around or not even the first
two DC fights like he seemed kind of
like half and half out like he didn't
really give how he's asking me like me
and Stephen never talk about fighting he
doesn't really watch fights he's not
even like a really big fan of the sport
no we spent the whole dinner talking
about fighting techniques and wow
footwork and movement and I was like
damn I didn't even know you knew any of
that stuff you know like he's just not
into it so mentally he's he's focused
for sure